it has impacted Las Vegas's 10th year
here in our city a Grassroots
organization created by Maureen romito
and it donates to local charities so
this year impact Las Vegas you guys are
looking to to donate a hundred thousand
dollars that is our goal we have been
slowly growing in membership over the
past 10 years and last year we hit 83
members so we're hoping to get another
20 so we can give out a hundred thousand
dollars in June of next year so let's
talk about what impact LV is I so it's a
collective group correct and you started
this with the idea of what being able to
give more exactly I wanted to be able to
make a difference because this is my
community I love this community and as
one individual you know my last name is
in Gates or Buffett or even win I didn't
think I'd be able to do enough to make a
true difference when I learned about
Collective giving and it was an easy
thing to talk to other women women about
and we started very small and slowly
built over the 10 years of having many
of us put in a thousand dollars by
December of each year we then combine it
into one total and a hundred percent of
that thousand dollars is given out in
June of the following year and the
amount we give is based on how many
members we end the previous year with
okay so this is twofold here uh Maureen
because number one you want to get more
members correct you want to get more
money so you can give more money correct
so how do you become a member to become
a member I encourage you to visit our
website which is
impact-lv.org okay I mean there's a
whole bunch of information about
membership the only requirement is that
you be a member you donate a thousand
dollars by the end of the year and you
vote for who's going to actually get the
Grant in June of the following a big
chunk of money okay and you're a
non-profit so being a member and
donating that money is a write-off
correct okay so now let's move on to
getting non-profit so there's so many
here in our community that that need
money a hundred thousand dollars could
go a long way how do they find out about
this we have we have been building our
mailing list and we try to get the word
out every year about that we're doing
training for all of the non-profits in
the valley in October okay which is
tomorrow morning we're doing the
training out at Roseman University of
Health Sciences our very first grant
recipient 10 years ago where we're going
to be telling them exactly how we give
out the money okay how to submit a
letter of inquiry how to apply we
actually even walk them through our
entire evaluation process of how our
members could volunteer to review each
of those letters of inquiry and Grant
applications that we get and score and
decide who do we really want to learn
more about and then we narrow right we
narrow it down through the months of
January through May and then in June all
our members get together there and
review the two finalists and vote each
one of us gets one vote and chooses
who's going to actually receive the
funds excellent now I we're running out
of time but really quick some of the
places that you have helped uh you
mentioned Roseman uh just run yes the
girls on the run girls in Las Vegas we
gave them several years ago we've also
this past year gave 83 000 to Klein
veterans fund the year before we bought
the refrigerated box truck for the just
one project with 67 000 so you guys have
done a lot of good work so this is a
call to action Maureen correct we want
you to join and we want to be able to
give to the non-profits so all the
information we'll have that posted on
our website as well but on your website
yes as well exactly excellent tomorrow
morning Maureen thank you so much for
waking up early with us and talking to
us about this incredible organization
congratulations thank you 10 years yes
and thank you for giving us this
opportunity to describe the word it's
good stuff Maureen thank you